temperatures on the planet are rising
almost everywhere but at different rates
in some countries animals will soon
start to suffer close to the equator
where it's already hot if it grows
warmer still
animals will begin to migrate if news
for example are no longer able to find
enough to eat on the parched plains of
the African savannah they'll go in
search of it then the Lions will start
to go hungry to survive the big cats
will have to follow their prey some
animals such as mountain goats will
initially retreat to higher colder areas
but if temperatures continue to rise
even the peaks might one day grow too
warm and then the species will die out
coasts are another barrier that limit
migration
many species of fish are already
reacting to warming oceans herring and
cod are both deserting the North Sea for
the colder regions around the pole other
species will profit from rising
temperatures the mosquito that carries
malaria will spread bringing the deadly
disease to more and more countries
climate change could eventually drive
species to evolve giving rise to new
adaptations what's clear is that
changing habitats and food sources will
have serious long-term consequences for
animals and for human beings as well